okay so the topic of this video is going
to be chemical energy and a molecule
called adenosine triphosphate ATP you
know here's a structural drawing of an
ATP molecule and here's kind of a more
three-dimensional realistic diagram of
an ATP molecule so what we're gonna do
is we're going to learn about this
molecule called ATP let's get started
alright as we discussed chemical energy
and ATP our food that we eat will be you
what will supply the glucose and the
lipids that are required to build ATP
molecules so you know in the picture we
have a plate of pasta here you know
pastas high in carbohydrates and glucose
is a carbohydrate
well there's also lipids in the foods
that we eat and so glucose from our
foods and lipids from our foods are
gonna be used to build ATP molecules
adenosine triphosphate and so energy for
our cells to do work will be stored in
the bonds of an ATP molecule so here's a
molecule of ATP and particularly you can
see the three phosphates member it's
called triphosphate you can see the
three phosphates on the left of this
diagram that's typically where the
energy for cells to do work is going to
be stored in between those bonds holding
the phosphates together and so if we
look at this more simplistic diagram
right here we can see adenosine
triphosphate the blue peas there's three
phosphate three peas stuck together
and the my notes say that energy is
released when that third phosphate is
broken off and so that third the bond
that holds the second to the third
phosphate together the bond that holds
the second P to the third P that bond is
fairly unstable and it's easily broken
and watched this when that third
phosphate is broken energy is released
energy usually in the form of heat is
released and that heat will kind of
stimulate cells to to do various
functions and notice what's left over
you have two broken remains of ATP left
over and when you have the
a will you have the adenosine
diphosphate I hope you see why it's
called diphosphate dye is a prefix that
means two so the molecule on the left
that's left over
it's called adenosine diphosphate and
there's that broken off phosphate on the
right still okay so now that that third
phosphate has been broken off ATP can
actually be recreated
so notice you have adenosine diphosphate
ADP on the left and that broken
phosphate on the right well with the
addition of energy from the food that we
eat in various enzymes that broken
phosphate can be reattached to recreate
ATP this way our cell can have more ATP
for more energy so if we again take a
look at an ATP molecule here well when
that third phosphor phosphate is broken
off that's going to release energy for
ourselves to do work and then what
you're left over with are the broken
pieces you have the adp and that broken
phosphate well with energy from the food
that we eat that broken phosphate can be
reattached to adp to recreate a teepee
now this is actually called the ADP ATP
cycle this process continues over and
over from from birth until death okay
when we look at the process of digestion
you know digestion the think about the
purpose of digestion and simply break
the food that we've eaten into usable
molecules once the food that we've eaten
has been broken down into usable
molecules those usable molecules will
hopefully help create ATP and so here's
a hamburger pretending to just eaten
this hamburger for lunch if we zoom into
the hamburger you know we can see that
you know there's complex sugars inside
of hamburgers and a complex sugar is
again made up from smaller simple sugars
a complex sugar you might remember is
actually called a polysaccharide and the
simple sugars if you recall are called
monosaccharides well through the
digestion that complex sugar will get
broken down into its simple sugar
components well let's just folk
on one simple sugar so if we just focus
on one simple sugar through the bra
through the breakdown of this one simple
sugar for instance glucose glucose is a
simple sugar through the breakdown of
glucose ATP is going to be created now
higher calorie foods will produce more
ATP molecules because higher calorie
foods have more of those glucoses in
them and so of course the more glucose
there is the more ATP will be created
now when we look at here's a diagram of
glucose you know one molecule of glucose
through a process that we're gonna learn
later on this chapter called cellular
respiration one glucose molecule will
actually be used to make up to 36 ATP
molecules and it's even more when you
look at a lipid here's a triglyceride a
lipid remember triglycerides are 3 fatty
acids connected to a glycerol head and
so one triglyceride can actually yield
up to 146 ATP molecules so you see we
get a lot more ATP from fats now that
doesn't mean we go out and eat a lot a
lot a lot of fats to make more and more
and more ATP because there's always so
much ATP we can use in a day if our body
produces more ATP than can be used of
course the energy will be stored and
stored in the form of fat now what about
proteins you know proteins are common in
the foods that we eat but notice how how
you know the proteins are not usually
digested to build ATP when you look at a
protein here's a picture ever again of a
chain of amino acids which is what
proteins are made from when you look at
a picture like this when proteins are
broken down those amino acids are
usually going to be used for other
processes so those amino acids I have I
have to be used elsewhere so the ATP
typically comes from the carbohydrates
in glue and glucose that we eat and from
the lipids that we eat
so to kind of wrap up this video here
when we look at the energy on earth it
really starts with the Sun so most life
on Earth relies directly or indirectly
on the Sun I do say most because there
is this peculiar group of creatures in
the deepest bottomless parts of the
ocean we'll get to those in a moment but
most life relies either directly or
indirectly on the Sun you know I thought
these were just very pretty images right
here various images of our Sun taken
from NASA satellites different light
filters on them showing the different
kinds of energy that the Sun can give
off well when we look at directly
organisms that directly rely on and the
Sun for energy would be autotrophs such
as plants no plants are not the only
autotrophs but the most common want and
plants obtain energy directly from the
Sun by doing photosynthesis so do some
cyanobacteria there's some
photosynthetic bacteria so do algae
these are things that directly get their
energy from the Sun indirectly let's not
forget that you know consumers
heterotrophs such as this animal this
rabbit here you know rabbits are
herbivores and they eat plants and then
plants feed directly on sunlight so the
rabbit doesn't get energy directly from
the Sun the rabbit gets energy directly
from the plant the plant gets energy
directly from the Sun let's not forget
the meat-eaters out there such as the
wolf you know the Wolves get energy
indirectly from the Sun wolves get their
energy directly from rabbits or some
other small you know rodent perhaps a
mouse or something or a rat so wolves
will get their energy directly from
eating some kind of smaller animal which
that smaller animal before it was caught
by the wolf you know fed on a plant
which got its energy directly from the
Sun so like my notes say most life
relies on the Sun directly or indirectly
but the exceptions would be the keema
troves you know here's a picture of an
underwater hydrothermal vent and you can
see that some black smoke billowing out
of this hydrothermal
a little crack in the crust and so all
this smoke is coming out from the mantle
of the earth and there are organisms
down there called keema Tropes well
first of all it in that black smoke
there are there's a gas that called
sulfides that are being released in into
the the ocean water there are bacteria
down there called keema troves that will
feed on those sulfides so there's a
unique group of bacteria that will feed
on those sulfides in order to make their
ATP and this is a process called
chemosynthesis and the bacteria that do
chemosynthesis are called keema troves
but even though this is a rare exception
I do want to stress the top of the notes
most life on Earth relies directly or
indirectly on the Sun to make their
energy so there you go you can pause
this video and you know try to answer
these questions if you're in my biology
class put your answers on a separate
sheet of paper I'd love to check your
answers before school or after school
for accuracy good luck